CRAIG CORNELIUS: Good afternoon.
My name is Craig Cornelius.
I work in the
internationalization team
at Google.
And I'm very pleased to present
our visitors from the Cherokee
Nation-- Roy Boney, who is
the manager of translation
services at the Cherokee
Nation, and Jeff Edwards, who
says that he should be called
a language technologist.
And this is the second visit of
the Cherokee Nation to Google.
And they're going to tell
you about the history
of the Cherokee writing system
from its origins to today
and going forward.
Welcome, Roy.
Welcome, Jeff.
[APPLAUSE]
JEFF EDWARDS: My
name is Jeff Edwards.
And I work with the
language technology program.
And the Cherokee Nation is doing
some really interesting things.
We're the first tribe to
have our own operating
system with Windows 8.
We're represented on the iPhone.
But the thing of it is
Cherokees have always
adapted technology--
not just recently.
We've always done it.
So I'm going to go through a
little history lesson with you
guys and show you that
every latest technology that
came out, the Cherokees
were quick to adapt.
And so this is the guy
that made it all possible.
He's our hero.
He's Sequoyah.
He is the guy credited with
developing the Cherokee writing
system.
Cherokee has 84
syllables right now.
There's some that
have been dropped,
some that have been
added, and all that stuff.
But right now, we
have 84 syllables.
And Sequoyah is credited
with developing those.
About two weeks after
Sequoyah developed this,
90% of all Cherokees were
fluent in reading and writing.
So it's really a very
important part of our history.
And this is a
Sequoyah signature.
I'd never seen this before
until the other day.
Roy showed me.
And it was really
neat to see that this
is a treaty that
Sequoyah signed in 1828.
And so we like to show that
just because he did exist.
And Sequoyah was
given this medal.
If you see a lot of
pictures of Sequoyah,
there's always something
around his neck.
And you don't really
know what it says.
Well, this is what
it actually says.
He was given this
medal for basically
inventing the
Cherokee syllabary.
And so that's what's
around Sequoyah's neck
in all the pictures.
And what gave Sequoyah the
idea to invent the syllabary
was he witnessed soldiers
writing letters back and forth.
And so he called those
"talking leaves."
And so that's what this
says here in Cherokee.
And of course, on the leaf is
Sequoyah's original syllabary,
which we'll show you
a little bit later.
But he wanted the
Cherokees to be
able to communicate
just like everyone else.
So he developed our
syllabary for us.
This is Sequoyah's
original syllabary.
It looks nothing like the
syllabary we have today.
We'll go into a little
bit of detail why that is.
But this is what he
came up with in 1821.
And like I said, it's really
a very [? script ?] syllabary.
And the ones we'll show
you here in little bit
looks nothing like that.
We always point this out, that
there's two characters here--
we'll go ahead and
highlight both of them.
The first character
that was highlighted
is actually upside down
by today's standards.
But at the time, it
was right side up.
So we'll talk about
why that got flipped.
And also, the other
character-- technology
failed us on that
character until recently.
And so we'll talk about that
a little bit later, as well.
And so they had to do a
handwritten modification
once they'd changed
Sequoyah's syllabary.
And so you'll see again that
the "do" character is still
upside down or right
side up, depending
on what year you're in.
And then there's that
character, as well.
And this is the reason why
the syllabary had to change.
On the far left is Sequoyah's
original syllabary.
And in the middle is the
handwritten equivalent
of what they came up with.
And of course, on the right
is a piece of typeset.
They could not make Sequoyah's
handwritten syllabary
into typeset.
And so if we wanted
to have a newspaper,
we had to be able to comply.
So that's why the syllabary
changed drastically.
It was to be able to
come up with the typeset.
And so that's the main reason
why the Cherokee syllabary
looks like it does today, so
we were able to do newspapers.
And this here is the
first thing ever printed.
It's the first five verses
of Genesis with the typeset.
And again, like
I said, we always
like to highlight that it's kind
of a funny joke that depending
on where you are
and what year it's
in if it's upside
down or right side up.
And this is the first edition
of the "Cherokee Phoenix"
newspaper.
It was printed in 1828.
And the really
neat thing about it
is, if you can see--
it's kind of blurry--
but it's in English
and in Cherokee.
And the thing about it was,
was the English was, of course,
in English.
But the Cherokee was not the
equivalent of the English.
This paper was used
to fight removal
from North Carolina
on the Trail of Tears.
It was kind of a
political-type piece.
So we kind of
snuck one in there.
And so if you could
speak Cherokee,
you obviously knew what it said.
And Cherokees-- we were always
printing basically everything.
We had our hymn books,
which is an example here.
And there's that
"do" character again.
And then here's where it
flipped in around 1836.
And the reason why
they did that is
because it looked too much like
some of the other characters.
And they didn't want
people to make a mistake.
And so they flipped
it over so instead
of having an upside-down V,
we now had a right-side V.
And it's like that today.
And here's the character
that got taken away.
It's the "ma" character.
And we recently
worked with Unicode
and brought this
one back to life.
And I'll go ahead
and read that to you.
You might not be able to see
it. "That the character 'ma'
has been omitted, and, as no
type has been cast for it,
your printers can
only represent it,
as I perceive they have done, by
breaking the English capital--"
I think that's a G. And so we
actually lost a character there
in history.
And this is the
syllabary chart everyone
is used to seeing today.
This was printed up in 1836.
And of course, there's
that "do" character.
And now, that character there--
what happened with him--
I don't know if it's
actually proven.
We can't prove it, but
it's a big speculation
is when it was
typed, since it has
that little second
bar on it, it has
a little square-looking
area right here.
And that was an ink blot.
Well, it's not supposed
to look like that.
Well, unfortunately, it
carried over from 1836
until about two
years ago, I guess.
And it always looked that way.
So an ink blot failed
us in the technology.
And it stayed that way
for a very long time.
And we recently got
that fixed, though.
This is a print of Exodus.
And so all materials
back in the day
were all printed in Cherokee.
And here's just
some more examples
of printings in Cherokee.
And they had song books.
That's an arithmetic book.
I don't know the
date on it exactly.
Do you know that for sure?
1850s, somewhere
around in there.
And so we had math books.
We had almanacs printed
entirely in Cherokee.
The "Cherokee Rose
Buds" was a newspaper
printed at Northeastern State
University in Tahlequah.
It actually had a
female seminary.
And they taught Cherokees
as well as whites.
They taught women and men at
the school, at the college.
And so that was really
cutting-edge for the time.
And here's a letter from Abraham
Lincoln to the Cherokees.
And of course, it is in
the Cherokee syllabary.
So we always thought that
was really neat, from 1863.
So even back then,
they were communicating
with high levels of
government because we're
a sovereign nation.
There's the Cherokee
constitution printed up
entirely in Cherokee in 1875.
And this one always
was really neat.
It's a Cherokee shorthand used
by the court reporters in 1890.
And it was a way of documenting
court cases that went on
in the Cherokee Nation with
the Cherokee shorthand.
And then, of course,
along came the telephone.
The Cherokees were first
have a telephone west
of the Mississippi.
And it's always a really
neat story behind that.
They had a line ran from
Tahlequah to Fort Gibson, which
is just a neighboring town.
And they called one another up.
And the guy instantly
said, it speaks Cherokee.
So they adopted it.
They were able to talk to
each other in Cherokee.
So we always thought that
was a real funny story.
And so we adopted the telephone.
And of course, we have
several spinoff newspapers.
The "Cherokee Phoenix,"
which I showed you earlier,
is still actually printed today.
This is the "Cherokee Advocate."
And this is the Fort
Gibson "New Era" paper.
They actually bought
the printing press out
but still continue to
print from the Cherokees.
ROY BONEY: The text
here-- when you
see Cherokee, that's
a Google font,
called Noto Sans Cherokee.
Which we're really happy
that Google developed for us.
But as Jeff was
pointing out, you
can see that all
through history,
we always adapted whatever
technology came around.
So you saw the previous
slide was a typewriter.
After statehood happened
in 1906 for Oklahoma,
that basically dissolved
the tribal governments.
And it caused a lot of disarray.
But the language still
continued, the writing
still continued.
And through all the decades
of the 20th century,
we adopted various typewriters
and different things.
This picture here is
actually from a typewriter
at Sequoyah's home
museum, which is
in a small town near
Sallisaw, Oklahoma.
It's the cabin in
which he lived when
he came to Indian Territory.
And this typewriter-- it's
the Hermes 3000 typewriter.
And if you're a
typewriter enthusiast,
you know the Hermes
typewriter was pretty popular.
But if you can
imagine typing all 84
characters on this typewriter.
So this is developed.
And what was cool about it is
if you go to this museum today,
the typewriter's
under a glass case,
but they'll let you actually
open it up and type on it.
So it still works,
and it's neat to see.
But inside-- this is a
picture of that typewriter
on the inside.
You can see all the type
heads and how intricate
it is with the Cherokee
syllables on it.
I just think that's
really neat to see.
So in the middle of
the 20th century,
the Cherokee language became
an endangered language.
And part of the
reason that happened
was because of technologies
like your radio and TV
and that types of things
that people didn't go out
to the communities so much.
They were more in
home and all this.
And there's also this
concept of relocation,
in which the federal government
took a bunch of native families
all across the country and
relocated them to big cities.
And the idea was
to get them jobs
and get them assimilated
to the mass culture.
And so a lot of Cherokees
were sent all over the place.
This particular gentleman
named Brian White
was sent to Chicago.
And while he was
there, he wanted
to keep in touch
with the Cherokee
people and his language.
So he developed this newsletter
called "The Cherokee Speaker."
And the reason why
I bring this up
is because, like I mentioned,
when statehood happened,
it devastated the tribes.
And so we didn't have
a formal organization
kind of running anymore.
But he wanted to continue
printing Cherokee materials.
Because all the printing
press and all that you saw
earlier was actually from
the Cherokee Nation itself.
The government was
publishing these things.
So without that
structure anymore,
we needed more independent
people putting out content.
So with this
newsletter, he solicited
people to raise funds to
develop a new set of type.
So in 1962, here it
says that he got $1,000
to actually make this type.
So when he got it, he started
making new Cherokee material
again.
This is a sample of that type.
This is about a squirrel here.
But you can see that he
still had this desire
to create Cherokee content.
The type became very popular.
And more people started making
more and more content with it.
This is a page from
a Cherokee primer
that was made in
1965 using that type.
And if you look
very closely at it,
you'll see how this
particular set of type
influenced how fonts and
stuff would look now.
In the '70s, the IBM
Selectric typewriter came out.
And that was very popular.
The Cherokee Nation
wanted to work with IBM
to create a Cherokee typewriter
element so they could
switch out the language with it.
But it proved to
be very expensive.
There is a gentleman named Scott
Gregory at Cherokee Nation who
was the CFO at the
time of the tribe.
And he told me that
when they did this,
IBM said they want $30,000
to manufacture these.
And at the time, that was quite
a lot of money for the tribe.
So the tribe worked out a
deal with a group in Hawaii
to actually manufacture
these for $5,000.
So several of these were made.
And they were distributed
to the communities.
And the communities
took them and started
making Cherokee
language materials that
helped combat the language
erosion that was happening.
And one of the big
things that occurred
from this particular development
is the 1975 Cherokee dictionary
by Durbin Feeling.
Durbin is considered
the foremost expert
on Cherokee language now.
He's been working in
the Cherokee language
for about 40 years,
longer than that.
He's devoted his
whole career and life
to preserving the
Cherokee language.
And this dictionary is
the standard dictionary
which we still use
for the language now.
I spoke with-- her
name's Adaline Smith.
She was the lady
that actually typeset
the dictionary at the time.
And she talked about using
that typewriter element
and having to switch it out.
And you can see it
has the numbers in it.
And that's representing the
tone lengths and all this.
She said you had to switch out
that for the numbers, and then
the Cherokee, and then the
English, back and forth.
And it was quite a task
to typeset this book.
And it's several
hundred pages long.
So you can imagine doing this
in the '70s at a typewriter,
doing this back and forth.
But they did it.
And we still have it,
and we still use it.
Like I said, it's
very important to us.
This is a really
important document.
Around this time,
too, in the 1970s--
this is dated 1976--
Hermann Zapf, who's
a very prominent typographer,
was developing a Cherokee font.
From what I've
heard about this--
I'm not sure this is
exactly true-- what
was happening at
this time was when
Apple was a fledgling company.
And they commissioned
him to develop a font,
but it never got produced.
But you can see there was
interest in the Cherokee
language even at that point.
It's called Sequoia.
In his book here, the
"Alphabet Stories" book,
if you have that,
you can actually
see-- he talks more
about in that book.
But about, I guess,
10 years ago,
the University of Wisconsin
took this and actually cast
some of the type in metal.
The project kind of fizzled.
I think they're still
trying to get it completed,
but it's interesting this still
has some interest for people.
In the 1980s, here's a picture
of Durbin as a younger man.
He worked with a
group out in-- I
think it was Louisiana to
develop the very first Cherokee
word processing software.
And again, the idea was--
the group was a law firm.
And Durbin says that
they were working
on a project about Cherokee
forensics for a case.
And they wanted to record
the testimony of the person.
So they developed this
software to do it.
Here's the first page
of print that they
made with that particular
piece, that word processor.
They presented it to Chief
Wilma Mankiller in 1987.
And it's just a
really cool document.
Durbin was kind enough to
share this page with me
from his personal papers.
So moving forward a bit
more, in the early '90s,
that's when the PC
became more popular.
And it was cheaper
and more affordable.
So more people had it in
their homes than ever before.
So people started
making Cherokee fonts.
This is considered probably
the very first Cherokee
font that was designed
by an actual Cherokee,
by Franklin McLain.
He collaborated with
a gentleman named
Al Webster who was a
computer scientist.
He came down to Cherokee Nation
in Tahlequah, and they met up.
And he helped design this font.
It proved to be very popular.
There were several
independent newspapers
that were published
using this font.
And just like any
society, we have
different political factions.
So they were fighting.
And it was kind of neat to see
that this was creating more
literacy in the modern era for
people to discuss and debate.
Around the same time, there
was a student at Yale.
He was interested in Cherokee
language and different writing
systems.
So he got a grant to
make a Cherokee font.
And Jeff kept pointing
out those two characters,
the upside-down
one and that one.
It's got that little ink
blot on the back of it.
That font here, this
design, that little mistake
came through since 1836 to now.
And then what happened
is he autotraced
that chart that Jeff
showed you earlier.
And that came through
with the autotrace.
So he donated his word to the
Cherokee Nation and the United
Kituwa band of
Cherokees, which is
another political
faction of Cherokees.
It's another federally
recognized tribal government,
but we have the same language.
And both governments developed
their own fonts out of it.
They took his work and
modified it slightly.
But the Cherokee
Nation font here
is the one that
really solidified
its status as the standard font
for a long time after that.
And you can see that little
blot came through again.
And we had this font
since about the year 2000.
And until maybe-- I don't
know-- like four years ago,
this is the standard
font that everyone
used to make Cherokee documents.
So if you would get
all these documents,
you'd have that little
printer error in there.
I think it's interesting to see
how technology can have such
a profound impact on
something like that.
This just shows
how one would type
using that font, the uppercase
and the lowercase keys
to access all the
different syllables.
So Unicode is very
important to us
because without it, we
wouldn't have access
to the technology we have now.
Back in the mid '90s,
again, Durbin Feeling
worked with Michael
[? Eberson ?]
to make the
application of Unicode
to get the Cherokee
syllabary encoded.
It took about five years.
But then, around the year
2000, Unicode 3.0 came out.
And that's when the
syllabary was formally
adopted into the system.
Like a lot of things,
this was new technology.
And it took a while
for people, at least
in the Cherokee
community, to pick it up.
So in the year 2003, Apple added
the Cherokee language support
to OS X. When that
occurred, a couple of years
after this, that's when we
discovered what Unicode was.
Like I mentioned, we were
using that other font before
for everything.
And we had all the problems.
We couldn't email.
We couldn't make
websites within those.
We did an image, all
those kind of thing.
So when we were using Apples at
the Cherokee language immersion
school, which was
established to teach children
the Cherokee language.
So they study
everything in Cherokee,
from pre-K to sixth grade.
So it's math, history-- all
the subjects in school's
in Cherokee.
And you were using
the Macs basically
to work as graphic designers
to make content for the school.
And one day when I was playing
around in the settings,
I saw this Cherokee setting.
I'm like, what is doing here?
And that's when we figured
out what Unicode was
and how it worked and what
it really meant to us.
So that was a really
major thing for us
to understand what that was.
So after we introduced the
laptops to the schools,
and the students started
using the Apple laptops
so they could do their homework
in the Cherokee language.
So that got us a really good
relationship with Apple.
And Apple got us in contact
with some people at Facebook.
So in 2009, Facebook
opened up their platform
to crowd-sourced localization.
So if you go to Facebook and
you go through the language
settings and you
change it Cherokee,
it'll switch your
interface to Cherokee.
And you can actually input
your own translations in it.
And the most
popular translations
are the ones that go live.
So that's the processes
that this is going through.
We're about-- I
think it's about 50%
through with this at the moment.
We have different people on
Facebook that are doing this.
But it's taking a while.
And it changes quite a lot, just
like a lot of this stuff does.
So the numbers fluctuate.
But it's about 50% now.
So our partnership
with Apple continued.
They helped us get
things in the schools.
And I said they had the support
for the language on their OS X
system.
So when the iPhone
was released, we
were still working
with them to get
this technology in the
schools with the assumption
that the mobile system
was like a smaller
version of the desktop system.
We said, well, why can't
we have Cherokee on here?
So in 2010, it was version
4.2, I think-- well,
it's got iOS now.
But whatever it
was at the time--
I forget what they called it.
But they released the update.
And it put Cherokee language
support on the system.
So that immediately put our
language on millions of devices
in the world.
That was the largest
explosion of Cherokee language
we've ever had.
A major thing that
happened with this, too,
is that-- at least
for me, personally.
I know other people
had the same response.
For the first time
ever-- I had been
active in trying
to learn Cherokee
and to get the
language going again.
But when this
happened, this actually
gave me the opportunity to
use the language every day,
because I have it in my pocket.
I can text.
It can email.
I can surf the web.
I can do all this.
And I did it every day since.
And it's really helped me
quite a lot for my language.
Because I come from a family
of fluent Cherokee speakers.
But most people
in my generation--
we didn't learn
it like we should
have for various reasons.
And this actually was
a major influence on me
to learn it and keep
using it all the time.
This is just some
screenshots from the iPad.
Since the iPad runs on the same
system, it's on there, too.
And this was, again, a
remarkable development.
In a lot of communities,
the older generation
don't use a lot of technology.
And when they saw this, a lot of
them had this look of surprise,
like what's our language doing
on something this high tech?
And they saw their kids
and grandkids using this.
And they're like, I
got to go get this.
So we have these elderly ladies
that have iPads and iPods
and iPhones so they
could communicate
with their grandchildren.
So I said that was
really quite neat to see.
And then we had to do
the little [INAUDIBLE].
So we had the
calendar and the times
and all that in Cherokee format.
So that leads us here to Google.
In 2011, we worked
with Craig here
to get the Google search
engine interface in Cherokee.
Our translators worked on that.
And I think what's really
neat about it, too,
is the virtual keyboard
that was developed for that.
In 2012, the Gmail system was
localized in Cherokee, as well.
And again, at Northeastern State
University there in Tahlequah,
we have a Cherokee
language degree program.
And the students there--
a lot of universities
use Gmail as their email system.
So they have access
to that there.
And there is the Noto
Sans Cherokee Google
font, which I think
is really great.
That was in 2013.
And it's a really nice font.
That's one thing
that we-- we showed
how that one font that we
had for the longest time--
we used it forever.
And then we had the printer
error in it, and all this.
So it's nice to see that our
language is getting out there.
And there are more
typographers out there
that are designing
Cherokee fonts now.
Even more Cherokees
are designing fonts,
too, but it's nice to see
this explosion of font design
for us.
Just this year,
the Cherokee Nation
put out a Cherokee speakers
playlist on YouTube.
So we created a lot
of digital content.
We record a lot of
Cherokee speakers
and cultural activities.
And we put it on
this playlist here.
So you can go there to the
Cherokee Nation's YouTube
channel and watch
the various videos
that we have about
Cherokee language.
All this also led to
partnerships with Microsoft.
So in 2012, we released
the Windows 8 localization
in Cherokee, which is just
the language interface pack.
So if you go to your
settings in Windows 8
and download the
interface pack, it'll
turn your interface
in the syllabary.
As part of this
project, too, Microsoft
developed the UI font
for the Cherokee language
called Cadugi.
In Cherokee, the
word "cadugi" talks
about-- it's meaning
working together
or the idea of community.
The word "skadugi" in Cherokee
actually means community.
So you can see how that word
is actually part of that.
And the reason why it was
named that is the idea here
with this particular
font is if there
are any other native
languages that
are wanting to do this
process with Microsoft.
And if they have any special
glyphs in their writing system,
it'll be housed in
this particular font.
So in the future,
other native languages
will be using this font if
they do this same localization
process.
Microsoft also took
all the translations
and put it on their website
here at their language portal.
So for a lot of our people
that are learning Cherokee
and they're using
this product, they
can actually go here
and search for what
all those translations say.
And it kind tells
them what it is.
So part of this process,
as you may know,
is localizing content is
an interesting process.
You get to see
how the people see
the world and their language
and how they translate things.
Here are just a few samples.
Email is [CHEROKEE], which
means lighting paper.
And the idea is it's paper,
and it's really fast.
So I think that's kind
of a neat idea of how
people see the technology.
Junk mail is [CHEROKEE].
And it just means something
bad or something unpleasant.
So a lot of times, if you stub
your toe, you say, [CHEROKEE],
like, ow, that hurt.
That's kind of what
that's coming from.
So it shows you how
people see junk mail.
No one likes it.
The word to follow, like to
follow someone on Facebook
or whatever-- [CHEROKEE]
is talking about you're
actually shadowing somebody,
rather than following them.
You're actually more
attached to them.
So again, these are
just a few samples
so you can see how the Cherokee
language sees the world a bit
differently.
And every language is this way.
When you're localizing
content, you're
actually making content
for that user base.
And you can see how
they approach the world.
An interesting
aspect of Cherokee
is how the language talks
about these concepts
of-- other languages, too, but--
you, me, his, her, their, our.
We have to change the
prefix of the word that
denotes the pronoun.
Like file-- "your
file" is [CHEROKEE],
versus "her file" is [CHEROKEE].
It's a slight
difference, but you're
denoting who you're
talking about.
And all these concepts
come into play
as part of this
localization process.
Just this year, we
released Office Online
in the Cherokee syllabary.
So if you go to onedrive.com,
with your Microsoft account,
you can login and have access
to Word, PowerPoint, and Excel
in the Cherokee language.
This is one of the most popular
piece of software in the world.
So it's neat to see the Cherokee
language in this setting.
So that brings me
to new developments
and what we're
working on right now.
We currently have
a Unicode proposal
in the pipeline to add
casing to Cherokee.
We're going to have
uppercase and lowercase.
And historically,
we've always had it.
It's just when the initial
application to Unicode
was put in in the mid '90s,
that, for whatever reason,
was not part of the application.
So the language itself
was encoded as just
it wasn't uppercase
or lowercase.
But you can see here-- this
is from the Gospel of John
in 1860, with the capital
letters highlighted.
In the math book we
showed you earlier,
you can see there's some capital
letters in Cherokee there.
In the handwriting,
too, we've always
had uppercase and
lowercase in it.
This here is actually
a modern test,
playing with fonts in uppercase
and lowercase and keyboard
layouts.
And so this is a very early
test of Cherokee bicameral text.
So like I said, the
current Cherokee text
is actually considered caseless.
I don't know how Unicode's
going to eventually decide
how this will be.
But the latest update I had,
this is how they explained it.
And I'm not a Unicode
encoder or whatever.
So this is kind of new to me.
But the basic suggestion is
to make the existing Cherokee
characters as uppercase.
So when they add
this new lowercase,
that'll be the new range.
But I don't know if that's how
it's going to pan out or not.
We'll see.
Like I said, it's
still in process.
This here is interesting to
me to see-- Cherokee Braille.
This is actually a really,
really recent new thing here.
Just this morning I got
a phone call about it.
But what happened is this group
called the Commonwealth Braille
and Talking Book Cooperative
in British Columbia contacted
the Cherokee Nation.
And they said that what they
do is they go through Unicode.
And all the languages
that are encoded
that don't have a Braille
version, they make it.
So they got to Cherokee.
And they said,
well, we want to do
a Cherokee version of Braille.
And this is what
they came up with.
And we were actually
just the other day
looking for someone that's
familiar with Braille
and Cherokee to be able to
actually test it and see
if it makes sense.
And just this morning,
I got a phone call
from one of my bosses
saying, we found somebody.
So this is still in process.
But you can see that our
language is still evolving.
We're still trying to get
in every format that we can.
This is something that's
very important to us.
There's quite a
lot of people that
are starting to
tweet in Cherokee.
It's still a very small group.
But there's a website
called indigenoustweets.com
that tracks indigenous languages
and how much of they're
being tweeted.
As I mentioned to
Craig earlier, when
we started collaborating with
Google, it was about 2010.
If you were to do a
search for [CHEROKEE]--
that's the word for
Cherokee there--
there were only like a couple
thousand results when you would
search for it.
This is from this morning.
There's over 3
million results now.
So in that four-year
time span, the presence
of the Cherokee language
online has exploded.
And the idea is to keep it going
because we want our language
to continue.
We want it to thrive.
And using technology
has been one
of the major tools in which
this is happening for us.
This is the point where
I might rib you a bit.
As part of this process,
the Cherokee language
is on most every major
piece of technology
you want to use now
except the Android system.
But what's interesting about
that is if you go to the store,
there are developers out
there that are actually
making Cherokee language
keyboards already.
The problem with
it is while you're
inside the keyboard
or the app itself,
you will see the language.
But once you go
outside of it, you'll
see the [INAUDIBLE]
or the blocks.
So you can see that
in this screenshot
here from the Google Play
Store for this plug-in here.
This is how the keyboard
looks currently.
Because I took this this
morning off my Droid tablet.
I installed that.
And you can see there's
no Cherokee showing up
on the device.
And then once you
actually enable it,
it shows up on the
keyboard there.
But once you get
outside the app again,
you can see it's not showing up
correctly on the device itself.
So that something that we would
like to see someday, maybe
Cherokee support on the Droid.
So we want to go
from this to this.
And I have a rooted Droid that
I did and installed it in that.
I've done several people in
the community's phones this way
that want Cherokee on it.
But the average
person isn't going
to sit there and
root their device
and install this
font and all this.
So it's kind of something
that we'd really
like to see happen for
the Cherokee language,
that Cherokee
support on the Droid.
But this brings
it all back around
to kind of where we started.
This is a screenshot of
the "Cherokee Phoenix" now.
It's still being published.
It's online.
And there's also
a paper version.
That's still in English
and in Cherokee.
So you can see that, as a
people, we still have it.
We still use it.
And it's very important
to us to keep it going.
We're a small group of--
it's a small community.
We don't have
millions of people.
millions of speakers.
But still, it's a very important
part of who we are as people.
With that, I'll wrap
up here and open it
to any questions you may have.
AUDIENCE: It was really
interesting to see
the various technological
words like junk mail
and all these
things that show up
in the Cherokee
version of Gmail.
Did those words exist
organically in the community
before this
localization took place?
Or were they invented
specifically for this?
ROY BONEY: Not really.
Email was something that was
kind of existing already.
But stuff like junk
mail-- no, that
had to be invented for
all these projects.
AUDIENCE: I noticed in
several different slides,
it looked like the syllabary
was organized in different ways
throughout its history.
I was curious-- how
is it organized today?
I understand that each
grapheme represents
a morpheme itself, one syllable.
So are they organized with a
semantic theme in one line?
Or are they organized by sound?
ROY BONEY: They're
organized by sound--
let me pull up that chart here.
They call it Sequoyah's
original arrangement.
And no one knows exactly what
the thinking was behind it,
because he didn't
document his process.
But as Jeff mentioned, when
the syllabary was formally
adopted by the
Cherokee Nation in 1821
and the community
started learning it,
within a really
short amount of time,
people became literate using
this language, this writing
system.
So this was his layout.
And however he did it,
for whatever reason,
people that were
in that time that
spoke Cherokee picked
it up really fast.
And the way it
goes, the sounds are
"ay," "ah," "lah," "gee,"
"nah," "wah," "way," "wee."
But it doesn't follow any--
it's not the English format,
I guess.
Because the modern version
of how arranged now,
it actually follows kind of an
English alphabetical setting.
So the top row is the vowels.
You have the "ah," "ay,"
"ee," "oh," "ooh," "uh."
But down the side, it
goes-- you can see a G.
So it goes "gah," "hah," "lah."
It's kind of following that
English alphabetical way.
And the reason this
happened is actually
a missionary that
did this arrangement.
And that's the one
that kind of stuck.
AUDIENCE: Looks like Japanese.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, exactly.
It does.
ROY BONEY: One back there or--
AUDIENCE: Did syllable
for said, the one that
looks very much like the
Latin four, the digit 4.
As we go forward-- in your
slides, I saw the kind of serif
at the end, that
it even disappears.
It almost looks like a
normal 4 in your later text.
How do you typically
distinguish it?
Just assume that the reader
would know from the context?
ROY BONEY: Yeah, a lot
of it is context based.
Anyone that's fluent in the
language will be writing.
And they'll know what that's
supposed to be saying.
The Cadugi font from
Microsoft-- let's
see if I can find it
here-- is actually,
at least in the modern era here.
This is actually
the first font that
was actually designed
and vetted in conjunction
with the Cherokee Nation itself.
All those other ones
were-- the fonts,
they were created independently.
But this one, actually the
designers from Microsoft--
we'd have conference calls
with the translation department
and other members of the
Cherokee language community.
And they would actually
go through this process.
And this is what
they came up with.
This is considered
the base shapes
of what the syllables would be.
So if you follow
this format here,
you'd get pretty close of
what most Cherokees would
understand, the bare
minimum, without the serifs.
AUDIENCE: In the beginning
of the first slides,
it was one handwritten.
And I think it had some vertical
squiggle lines between words.
So what's the status
today with punctuation?
Use just Latin punctuation
or no punctuation at all?
ROY BONEY: Yeah, it's just
the Latin punctuation.
This here actually
shows the original
and then how the modern
one kind of came out.
So if you see the ones
that look like a G--
AUDIENCE: And so the vertical
squiggly line have any meaning?
Is that a space between words?
ROY BONEY: That's
just separating
each of the syllables.
So there's one, and there's one.
That's all that is.
You're just separating.
But as far as
punctuation goes, we
don't have any special
punctuation at all.
AUDIENCE: So use Latin one,
or you don't use anything?
ROY BONEY: Yeah, we use Latin.
There are some people that
don't use punctuation.
They just go.
But most people use the
English punctuation.
JEFF EDWARDS: Most
recently, we brought back
the Cherokee number system.
ROY BONEY: Oh, yeah.
Sequoyah developed a
Cherokee number system,
which never really took off.
But we have an individual
named John Ross.
He's a translation specialist
at Cherokee Nation.
And he sat down and studied
the Cherokee number system.
And he deciphered how
it actually works.
And he has this whole system.
When Sequoyah made it,
he didn't have a zero.
So when John took it and
[? invented ?] the zero.
And it just all works.
So now it's kind of coming back.
JEFF EDWARDS: I think
he's up to a trillion now,
I think is what he's up to.
He's really far into it.
ROY BONEY: He just keeps
adding numbers and writing it.
So it's kind of neat to see.
AUDIENCE: So with the
focus to get the language
into modern technology--
is it solely
to just get the language there?
Or is it to use the other
features such as proofreading
and spell checking
and keyboard swipes
and stuff along those lines?
ROY BONEY: I'd love
to have all that.
Part of the stuff
with Microsoft--
we actually have a spell
check dictionary now.
And all that's
kind of developing.
It's not as robust
as other languages,
but that part of the technology
is starting to happen now.
Like on iOS, there's a
spell check dictionary
in there and all that.
And so it's slowly happening,
but we'd like to see of it.
And it has the
same problems, too,
when you get autocorrected.
You're like, I didn't
mean to say that.
AUDIENCE: There are
significantly more
symbols in Cherokee
that in Latin.
If I remember right, you
said 84, something like that?
ROY BONEY: 84, yeah.
AUDIENCE: So it was
very interesting to see
in the different
formats through history
that you went through how
those are accommodated
on the keyboards that existed.
It looked like a lot of
times it was using the Shift
or adding rows or
something like that.
So I was just curious
what the best system is.
Or if that seems to be
a significant impediment
for people in the past,
and if it slows down
typing to have to use
shifting all the time.
Or if there's something that's
being done in these more
current layouts
where they're less
constrained by the
physical device.
What's the best way
that you've found
that's most
convenient for people
who are trying to
write fluently?
JEFF EDWARDS: The way it started
out was there's 84 characters.
And so all punctuation is
gone from this typewriter.
We didn't have room for it.
And so you did the Shift key.
There's a few on there,
commas and stuff like that.
But most of the numbers
and stuff are gone.
And you use that Shift
key to toggle it.
And that basically carried
over into the modern times.
And that's actually
how I learned
how to start typing, with
this keyboard layout.
And I'm not going to lie to
you-- at first, remembering
where 84 keys are when you
have to shift is really hard.
But if you use it
every day, like I
did, for about 10 hours a day,
you get really fast at it.
But once we started
doing Unicode,
we got our phonetic keyboard,
which allowed us to type
the "tsa" instead of having
to hold the Shift key,
so that shifting stuff
no longer mattered.
We were just able to type
our phonetic sounds--
which I don't know if we
have any of those there.
But you could type that way.
And so I can go
faster in Cherokee
than I can in English
now, just because
of that phonetic keyboard.
So that helped tremendously.
ROY BONEY: On the
iPhone or iOS keyboard,
it has a sort of
phonetic typing system.
So if you're familiar with that
big chart that we keep showing,
here's the vowels, the "ah,"
"ay," "ee," "oh," "ooh,"
and "uh."
If you want to type
the sound "gee,"
you would type "ga" plus "ee,"
and it switches to "gee."
And also, if you hold down the
key, the whole row pops up.
But it's based on that
phonetic idea of typing.
And it works really well
for the touchscreen devices.
Microsoft followed
a similar format.
Slightly different, but
if you have Windows 8
and you have a
touchscreen device, when
you enable the
phonetic keyboard,
it goes to this touchscreen.
And it's still a
little bit tricky.
I think this is probably the
best touchscreen keyboard
that we've seen so far.
But Microsoft's just try to do
something different, I guess,
because the competition,
or whatever.
But it still works.
It is based off of
that phonetic idea
of how you would
type a language.
AUDIENCE: I was wondering
if you managed--
I guess you have a lot
of historical documents,
since the press has been using
this language for a long time.
Have you been able to
collaborate with anybody
to get any OCR technology so
you can scan these documents
and import them into a
Unicode searchable index?
ROY BONEY: There's been
a little bit of work
here at Google with
the [? tesseract ?]
group that does the OCR.
Not a lot has been done with it.
Part of the issue that
we've had with it is it's
not really user friendly.
For us, our
community to take it,
running commands
and all that stuff
is not something most
people know how to do.
So we haven't been able to
feed a lot of data into it.
But that's the only
one I know of that's
been actually done so far,
AUDIENCE: So it's
more just managing
the process of
running the software
and getting the data into it.
CRAIG CORNELIUS: To answer
that a little bit more,
there is a group in
the research building
that is doing multilingual OCR.
And they've worked with
the Cherokee a bit,
but we haven't done
a lot of testing yet.
We'd like to do it, but
getting the scanning--
there are books in the
Cherokee libraries,
for example, that
we'd like to scan.
But unfortunately, the number of
books that have been suggested
is in the hundreds.
And Google scanning works
well 10,000 books and above.
So getting organizational
and logistics is the harder
part than the actual
OCR, I believe.
But we'd love to work on
some of those projects, too.
AUDIENCE: So I
guess I'm interested
in the political shift that took
place in the Cherokee Nation.
Because it almost seems
like when Sequoyah developed
the syllabary, it
was pointedly very
different from Latin
script and sort of flew
in the face of the perceived
dominant culture of the time.
But now Cherokee
survival depends,
it seems from what you two
are saying, on the integration
with this mobile technology.
And all of these working
together to keep it alive.
So at what point--
was there an event
or was there a series of events
or splits in Cherokee history
over the question of whether
to isolate or to adapt
and integrate?
ROY BONEY: There's a
long history there.
Actually, when Sequoyah was
developing the writing system
itself, he had a
lot of resistance.
There were Cherokees that
said, we don't need that.
That's the invader technology.
Or not technology,
but that's their way.
We don't need that.
He actually worked on it over
the course of about 10 years.
And then halfway through
it, his work was destroyed.
Some Cherokees actually burned
down his cabin with his work
inside, said, we
don't need this.
But he started again.
They say that he had even
more characters, like 100
or something in it.
And when that happened,
he modified it again
and came up with
what we have now.
But after it was adopted in
the 1820s, in this era in 1820s
is when the removal
policy was being
debated in Washington, DC.
And in the 1830s, when
the policy was passed--
and when that was passed,
there were factions.
There were Cherokees
that said, we just
need to give in and
just adapt and adopt
into the mainstream society.
And some said, no, we don't.
And they kept fighting.
And they kept resisting.
And they kept the writing
system as part of it.
Because a big part
of the content that
exists from that era
still is a lot of it
was traditional knowledge
and traditional medicine
that was written in
the Cherokee language.
And over the years, as the
language itself diminished
in the number of
fluent speakers,
the writing system
became almost sacred.
And so some people
would say, you
don't need to learn that because
that's sacred knowledge only
reserved for certain people
that are supposed to know this.
And so as technology changed,
and in the 20th century,
when people started seeing
that more people are losing
the language, the idea
changed, like, well,
we need to stop
thinking this way
and adapt new ways of
communicating and using it
still.
And so that tension
is still around.
There are people that
don't like this still,
what we're doing
with technology.
But for the most
part, it's positive.
We say this quite a lot when
we do these presentations.
There was a person
that said, talking
about putting the language
out there online and stuff.
They thought, well, what
if someone out there
tries to became a
Cherokee medicine man,
and they're not Cherokee?
And they don't know this.
They weren't raised this way.
And then, well,
the answer is, you
don't become a doctor
by googling stuff.
You have to actually go be
trained formally to do this.
So as I said, there
is a tension there.
And we're still dealing
with that change.
But using technology has been
a big step forward for us.
AUDIENCE: Since this is
going to go on YouTube,
I just actually want to make an
announcement regarding Unicode.
Actually, just last
month around this time,
Unicode technical committee met.
I actually represent Google to
that committee, as some others.
So we actually approved the
Cherokee lowercase letters,
basically.
So they will be in
Unicode 8, which
will be released next
year around this time.
And the characters
are also safe to use.
So we've also frozen
the code points.
So you can basically-- if you
figure out with the technology
partners you have, you can
sort it into characters today.
So they are approved,
and they should work.
And [INAUDIBLE].
ROY BONEY: That's good news.
All right, that's great to hear.
CRAIG CORNELIUS: Well,
all good things must end.
I would like us all to thank
them for the presentation.
[APPLAUSE]